I never thought I'd say this but in 2020
Windows has become the ultimate platform
for the web developer Windows has become
awesome for a variety of reasons but one
of the biggest reasons is a feature
called windows subsystem for Linux or
WSL which allows you to run a real Linux
environment on Windows without a virtual
machine once you have it set up you can
just open the command line and start
working with the filesystem like you're
on Linux and that's because you are in
fact on Linux and windows at the same
time you can be working on your server
code and BIM on one screen while working
with Adobe Photoshop on the other screen
which is software that you can't install
on Linux as a full-stack developer you
can link Linux two Bs code allowing you
to use any Linux based utility and spawn
actual Linux processes from your
application code today's video is a
complete guide to setting up a modern
web development environment on Windows
with Linux you'll learn how to set up
basically everything you need for a
professional web development environment
including things like browsers get
nodejs docker and more and I'll throw in
a bunch of little pro tips that
hopefully make your life easier
or at the very least make your system
look like it's being operated by a 10x
developer if you're new here like and
subscribe and grab the full write-up to
copy and paste some of the commands from
fire ship IO the first thing you'll need
is Windows 10 and to get things started
we'll install windows subsystem for
Linux which allows us to install Linux
on Windows one thing I'd like to point
out first is that there's WS l1 + WS l2
they both provide the same user
experience WS l2 is just an improvement
of the underlying architecture primarily
to make things faster WS l2 is not
generally available as of today but it
will be in the next month or two and the
upgrade process should be relatively
seamless to get started we first need to
opt into WS l go to the Start menu then
open a new powershell session as an
administrator paste in the following
command which you can find from the full
article and then it will prompt you to
restart your system after your system
reboots head over to the Microsoft Store
if you search for Linux you'll see the
option to run Linux on Windows you can
install one or more of these distros and
then switch between them as needed
Ubuntu is always a solid choice and in
fact the organization that publishes it
canonical collaborated with Microsoft to
develop WSL
the first place once installed you
should be able to open up the command
line and run wsl flag l to list out your
Linux versions now if we just type WS L
it will enter a terminal session for our
default version and what's awesome about
this is that we're running actual L 64
Linux binaries it's not emulated or
modified so you can run all the apps and
tools that you can on a real winix
machine on top of that you can access
the Windows file system here and run
Windows apps here as well in the past I
used to run a dual boot system where I
had windows on one partition in the hard
drive and Linux on the other if I was
working on web development I would
switch over to my Linux environment
but when I needed to work with an Adobe
program or Microsoft Excel
I'd have to restart the system and
switch over to the Windows OS that's
obviously very inefficient and the two
operating systems don't share any files
or functionality but with WSL we get the
best of both worlds and it's really been
a game changer for me now another thing
that has always sucked about Windows is
its terminal luckily that's getting an
overhaul as well and we can install it
from the Microsoft Store with this
terminal we can easily open up a session
in PowerShell or Linux if you've never
used Linux here are some useful commands
to move around the file system use LS to
list the contents of a directory use M
Kader to create a new directory and then
CD to move into it now use touch to
create a new file if you're a 10x
developer you'll use VI to edit this
file with bin but most of us can just
use code to launch vs Co to edit the
file you can prefix any command with
sudo to run it as an administrator in
Ubuntu we can install new software with
the apt package manager and one package
that you'll definitely want is SL once
installed you can run SL from the
command line to run a train through the
terminal so that's cool in all but
there's still one big problem our
terminal is really ugly so how do we
make the command line look cool well the
first thing you should know is that
whenever you start up a new Linux
terminal session it runs a startup
script that you can configure in this
bash or C file
bash is actually a programming language
that you can use to run code from the
terminal but the only thing you really
need to know for right now is that there
is an environment variable in this bash
RC file called ps1 it represents the
primary prompt string value currently
it's showing the username followed by
the system name and then the full
working directory we can change it by
modifying the bash RC file in the home
directory
go down to the bottom of the file and
export a new value for ps1 and the full
article I have a few different examples
of different values and variables that
you can use here for now I'll go ahead
and show a timestamp so I know when I
ran this command then I'll use the base
name of the current working directory to
shorten the prompt string so that's one
way to go but I think we can still do a
lot better by installing Z shell because
that will give us access to an awesome
tool that will make us feel like a 10x
developer called oh my gosh we can
install it by fetching its remote URL
with curl and it will give us access to
a bunch of themes and plugins for the
command line but at this point you
probably have no idea which theme you
should use open up the route Z SHRC file
then change the theme variable to random
now every time you open up a new
terminal session you'll have a
completely different theme when you land
on one you like you can copy its name
and use it as the theme variable ok so
now that we have an awesome-looking
terminal we need to hook everything up
to vs code to do that we need to install
the remote WSL extension it makes it
possible to open up a vs code window
that's fully integrated with either one
of your Linux distros or with Windows go
ahead and hit ctrl shift P to open up
the command palette in BS code you'll
see the option to open a new window in
WS l or reopen the current window when
you do so you'll see this blue box down
in the left corner that shows how you're
running Ubuntu here now if you open up a
terminal session with control backtick
it'll be running z shell on your Linux
OS now everything you do here including
the code you write will happen on Linux
notice how I'm console logging process
dot platform be an oj ass if I run this
script with node from the current window
you can see it returns Linux as the
platform if I do the same thing from the
other window it logs win32 is the
platform this is really cool because if
you also run you bunty on a server you
can have the same low-level dependencies
that your server will have and that can
make things easier when it comes to
back-end development speaking of which
one of the most important low-level
dependencies for a web developer is no
js' Ubuntu doesn't come with note
installed by default so if you run node
from the command line you should get not
found there's a few different ways you
can install node but I think the most
reliable is with NPM you can install it
in bash using this curl command or if
you're using zsh like we are we can just
add it as a plug-in to our zsh RC file
in either case it will install node
version manager on your system giving
you access to the nvm [ __ ]
use it by running nvm install with the
version that you want to install if you
go to node.js org it will tell you the
recommended version for most users
definitely install that one but you
might also want the latest bleeding-edge
version as well with NB m you can
install both and then run NB m use to
switch between them in either case you
should now have access to both node and
NPM from the command line and that gives
you a super easy way to manage your node
installation on Linux
now another essential low-level
dependency is get it is installed on
ubuntu by default but we might want to
update to the latest version for git we
can use the apt package manager to get
and install it that will bring us up to
date but it's also a good idea to set a
global username and email address we can
do that by running git config and
setting a few global values that way our
commits are tied to our username so we
can be blamed when something goes wrong
and one other little pro tip here is to
cache your get credentials if you push
to a remote repository like github it's
going to ask you for your username and
password for every operation running
this command will cache your username
and password for one hour if you're
using git for version control there's a
good chance you're also using github so
we're also going to install the
brand-new github CLI for Linux we need
to go and download the Debian release
from the github Docs after its
downloaded we can use the D package
install command and point to that file
and that gives us access to the gh
command we can use it to easily create
and manage repos on github and also
fetch a list of issues or pull requests
so that takes care of our get setup but
another thing we should talk about is
docker on Windows I highly recommend
installing the docker desktop app
although I think you need Windows Pro to
install it it provides a really nice way
to manage any containers running on your
system it provides a list of all your
containers if you click on one you can
go and inspect the logs and view stats
about that container and personally I
find it more intuitive to work with
docker and an app like this versus the
command line but currently the Interop
between WSL and docker is still in the
works if I have a container running and
try to access it from my Linux
environment you can see I get this error
that it's unable to connect in the
command line
there are ways around this but Microsoft
and docker are collaborating to add full
support in WSL 2 if you're running WSL 2
today you should see the option to an
experimental support which will connect
docker in both these Linux and Windows
environments now if you're just getting
started as web developer you probably
don't need docker anyway it's not
totally essential like nodejs or get but
something you'll probably want at some
point now the last thing I'll mention is
that if you're doing web development
you'll definitely want a few different
browsers installed when working on a
front-end JavaScript app I generally
prefer to debug it in Chrome
chrome has a very powerful set of
JavaScript debugging tools and there's a
BS code extension that you can install
to connect Chrome directly to the vs
code debugger so that's cool and all but
if I'm doing anything related to design
or CSS I'm definitely going to be using
Mozilla Firefox compared to Chrome it
has a much better suite of CSS tools for
doing things like flexbox and grid and
that's why you see me use firefox in my
CSS videos and also I recommend
installing brave so you can inspect your
site in a privacy conscious environment
if your web app collects analytics data
or does anything with user
authentication some of your features
might not work and brave as browsers
like this become more popular you should
definitely consider the user experience
there as well now at this point I could
probably talk about another 500
different tools or vs code extensions
but hopefully this gives you a good
starting point to start developing full
stack web applications on Windows with
Linux of course if you want to learn
more about productivity as a developer
consider becoming a pro member at fire
ship IO most of my courses contain a
video dedicated to productivity based on
the stack that we're working with thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one